welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss in recent revelations of mutants in
the mcu have turned us all into
sentinels and a mutant hunt the specific
way kamala khan was established as a
mutant genealogically has us wondering
what other mcu newcomers with mysterious
power sets might also come with a 90s
x-men rift sometime soon now i too found
it suspicious that ned suddenly acquired
the powers of sorcery and spider-man no
way home but a character marvel studios
doesn't have to share with sony whom
kamala will soon team up with with a
backstory equally suss is monica rambo
aka photon co-star to kamala khan and
carol danvers in the upcoming the
marvels and now when i go back to
re-watch wandavision something i do on a
weekly basis just because i like to
wallow in my shame a lot of the loose
ends from that series seem to point in
the same direction now after ms marvel
that monica rambo in the 616 mcu may be
a mutant
now to be clear in the marvel comics
monica rambo is not a mutant she gets
her powers by helping a colleague of her
grandfather track down a device that
drains energy from other dimensions tech
that she tries to destroy with her bare
hands that ends up bombarding her with
extra dimensional energy that allows her
to convert her body mass into any form
of electromagnetic energy no x gene no
no no no but then again not being a
mutant in the comics didn't stop the mcu
from making kamala khanna
monica rambo goes mostly by spectrum in
the marvel comics but also had the rank
of captain marvel at one point and also
goes under the moniker of photon and it
seems like photon is what the mcu is
going to be calling her based on photon
being the call sign of her mother maria
and kamala and bruno referencing photon
gloves in episode one of that show but
the episodes of one division were super
cryptic about monica's past and when
exactly she acquired her powers we know
that she fully powered up into her final
photon form in episode seven when she
pushed through the hex wall
[Music]
and notice at the beginning of that clip
there was an initial energy charge sound
effect that sounded a lot like the sound
of the infinity stones charging up
thanos's gauntlet infinity war
[Music]
a sound effect i only recognize because
i have one of those infinity gauntlets
and sometimes something just bumps it in
my closet and it starts to make that
noise and it freaks me out like thanos
what are you doing in my closet also you
can come out whenever you're ready i've
seen some of those photos
but that sound effect was because the
hex wall was composed of cnbr cosmic
microwave background radiation the
electromagnetic radiation that has
existed in the universe since the big
bang which is the event that also gave
us the infinity stones meaning that
monica and wanda and carol were all
enhanced by cosmic radiation derived
from infinity stones but that's not all
because one of vision episode 8 showed
that wanda's powers did not originate
with the infinity stone as a child years
before hydra experimented on her she was
able to cast a low level probability hex
to keep that stark warhead from
detonating in a video recently i
explained how in the mcu it seems like
three components are needed for the
activation of any superpowered mutant
one a genetic predisposition aka a
mutant gene that serves as a lock
mechanism to an energy source that the
mutant draws power from the pulsing
energy on the other side of that locked
door waiting to be opened up and three a
trigger event that unlocks that mutant
gene that enables the mutant to use that
energy that trigger could be puberty or
some personal trauma for many of us
puberty is traumatic enough in wanda's
case i think the trauma was not the
infinity stone exposure that merely
amplified what was already there and in
monica's case while that cosmic
radiation amplified her into photon
there is evidence that other things were
going on with her long before that
moments before she passed through the
hex wall she rips the hatch clean off of
that rover and it flies off its hinges
now you could say this happened after
she had previously gone through the hex
wall twice when she first went into it
and then when wanda threw her back out
but in the flashback to her post-blip
return back in episode 4 a man
re-materializing bumps into her and gets
completely leveled he has at least a
foot on her and she barely budges and
then after she got ousted from the hex
in episode five there was this odd
moment with the sword doctor we're gonna
need to take these again there's
something wrong with the machine those
are blank like i said well what about
her labs i need another blood draw
no no no we're done here
she does that and for me this is the
most suspicious because while it
arguably makes sense that monica's scans
would come out blown out after her
radiation exposure the doctor
re-examining her blood is what freaks
her out this tells her that monica knows
that there is something weird about her
blood that would show up in her dna that
she does not want sword to detect now if
there's one thing i've learned from
watching thor love and thunder it's that
it takes a lot of energy to be a god but
for the rest of us the g-fuel has
crammed plenty of that godly get up and
go into their new lightning lemonade
sparkling hydration inspired by marvel
studios thor love and thunder
that's pretty good lightning lemonade in
these 17 ounce bottles is a perfect
summer drink in that it's everything you
love about thor and lemonade in this
same bottle it's got no calories no
sugar and no caffeine dehydration ends
here and now what it does have are
focused aminos and a bunch of
antioxidants and vitamins to keep you
hydrated no matter what you're doing
making videos gaming or trying to sort
out your relationship with jane foster
you can get lightning lemonade at
gfuel.com as part of the hydration
collectors box if you want sparkly and
hydration bottles you can find those on
gfuel.com and coming soon amazon.com so
click the link in the description and
use code new rockstars to get 30 off and
thanks to g fuel for sponsoring this
video
it actually reminds us of bruno running
scans of kamala's dna on his tablet
first name is marvel episode 2. so it
looks like your power isn't coming from
the bank
it's coming from within you
like the bangle unlocked the superhuman
part of you and then revisited famously
in the finale kamala there's something
different in your genes like a mutation
and i cannot let this go but it is super
weird that bruno collects kamala's dna
and keeps his information on his tablet
i don't care if he's smart enough to get
into caltech early it is crazy and
creepy that he has this information
anyway like kamala monica may have
something unusual about her dna
something that enhanced her body from a
young age enough to stand around when
dudes slam into her in the hospital and
to blast hatches off of rovers and
monica knows this but may or may not
know why the why is that i think this is
another example of a mutation an x gene
so if we run monica through those three
components she would have one a genetic
precondition of a mutant gene two she
draws energy from the cmbr and three all
that would be left is what is her trauma
what's her trigger event wanavision
hinted at this history as monica
re-materialized after the blip you could
hear voices of her mother maria rambo
talking with carol danvers and nick fury
during the 2019 captain marvel film
lieutenant
we hear these voices return as monica
pushes through the hex wall in episode
seven
baby it's too dangerous
[Music]
[Music]
when they were handing out kids they
gave her the toughest
ah and that final shove comes right
after carol's line and in terms of mood
and potential trauma monica looks uh
well motivated i mean fellow sentinels
if we are seeking trauma to do some
armchair psychoanalysis here which is
hard for me to do because i'm at least
an undiagnosed version of monica's other
name spectrum it seems to me that monica
holds carol responsible for her mother
getting cancer and monica wishes that
she herself could have been able to glow
like auntie carol and meet her mom
halfway in space to save her from auntie
carol and now blames carol for never
once visiting during maria's cancer
treatments that resentment was obvious
when jimmy wu brought up carol in
episode five well i'd argue that captain
marvel came close
her powers came from an infinity stone
too right we are not talking about her
we are talking about wanda
so really the trigger for monica could
have been her mother's cancer diagnosis
sometime after the events of captain
marvel when monica would have been a
young teenager that is what first
activated monica's mutant gene on a
small scale enhancing her body's
constitution until fuller exposure to
cosmic radiation fully powered her up
into the next woman bruno is going to
start tracking with this creepy app let
me know your thoughts on this theory and
follow me on instagram and twitter at
avos following the rockstar subscribe to
new york stores for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you